the main stories don't witches see true
what they say elves are the original
sorceress of the continent when humans
and monsters arrived else talk to you
miss had to come chaos into magic the
humans love to go
chaos is the most dangerous thing in
this world
without control chaos will you
so that's all like this to you monsters
and money it's all it needs to me
something out there weights fee
this child will be extraordinary
Yennefer imagine the most powerful woman in the world
do you have what it takes
you can't outrun destiny just because
you're terrified of it it's coming
I can't do this without you
no matter what you choose
you'll come out bloody
hi everyone happy comic-con week
continues we finally got our first
actual trailer for The Witcher series
with Henry Cavill all this stuff is
based on the books not so much on the
games I'll explain why that is and what
all the Easter eggs are going on there
are a couple storylines that they've
added to some that did not appear during
the books so I'll try to explain what
that is I will be doing episode videos
for this when it premieres later this
year so be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos I'll do some cool which our
giveaways when we start to get episodes
too so just starting at the beginning of
the trailer working our way to the end
just to be clear this is basically
covering most of the first book the last
wish may be a little bit of sword of
Destiny because that's the book where he
meets Ciri for the first time but
obviously you can tell during this
trailer she's a little bit older so
they've kind of done the Game of Thrones
things with the younger children the
younger characters on Game of Thrones
had to be aged up for the TV show
because the book versions of the
characters were so young that they were
never going to be able to find actors
that would be able to do a good job
so you see Geralt walking through town
and it looks like he's getting ready to
start a fight he gets him to fight with
these people this might be the events of
the butcher of blaviken can when he got that nickname if you're not familiar with the
mythology of the witcher's or their
history
witcher's are basically monster hunters
for hire there's a couple of moments
during the trailer where he's questioned
by Tris this is Tris saying do you think
that that's all there is and he's like
that's all there needs to be hunting
monsters taking money but what they're
teasing through the trailer is the idea
that he gets caught up in this larger
story that revolves around ciri they
keep referring to her during the trailer
as if she's this child of destiny she
has this secret power she has elven
blood in her they talk about elves at
the beginning of the trailer this is
ancient powerful rays that man
eventually tried to and take down
so the whole idea is there's no real
villain on the series everybody's kind
of terrible in their own way but some of
them are more terrible than others like
you see the nilfgaardian army coming to
massacre all the people of Cintra and
take over their territory but the first
couple of books a lot of the events that
you see during the trailer are a bunch
of short stories that just give you an
idea for who Geralt is why he behaves
the way he does his code of honor that
he operates by and they give you that
dialogue in the trailer words like
sometimes the worst monsters are the
ones we create that
the idea that sometimes the actual
physical monsters within this world are
not the real monsters sometimes humans
are the monsters so the butcher a blade
can wear he got that nickname is one of
those events where a bunch of people
tried to an innocent mage in Geralt
stood up for them and then wound up
all these mercenaries so that's
why they gave him the nickname butcher
of blade c'n then you finally see him
fighting a monster in this what looks
like abandoned castle this actually
might be king foltest his daughter which
is from that first story the last wish
where he gets hired by a king to rescue
his daughter who's been turned into a
monster through a curse
so Geralt tries to save her but mostly
you just see him fighting this monster
but the whole idea like you see this
bloody hand is that it's actually King
vultus daughter that eventually he does
help save then you see Geralt being
healed talking to trigger this is
probably happening right after that
event because tris is one of the first
relationships that he has she works for
king foltest but that's one of the very
earliest stories that you get in the
books so I guess think that's one of the
ways that they opened the series up in
the first couple of episodes you'll ask
how come he only has one sword on his
back most of the time in the books he
only walks around with his once steel
sword on his back his silver sword he
actually holsters on Roche his horse so
we got a picture than the other day and
if you look over here in the corner you
can actually see his silver sword hilt
poking out on the side of Roche
so TV show Geralt does have both of his
sores he does have the yellow cat eyes
these eyes that he has here when he's
fighting this trigga
are just potion eyes he mixes different
types of potions depending on what the
needs of his mission are if he's
fighting different kinds of monsters it
takes different kinds of potions they
sort of jumped forward in time in the
books though when you see ciri here in
the woods with the dryads in the Dryad
Queen these are the events where Garrett
winds up meeting her for the first time
and Cirie is forced to choose whether or
not she stays with the dryads
or whether she goes back with Gerald and
eventually she chooses to go with Geralt
but then I know a lot of people see her
later in the trailer in the desert and
I'm like wait a minute doesn't that
happen in the way later books what's
going on here is she traveling to the
realm of the elves because some of the
elves within the context of the series
this ancient race inhabit a whole other
world that you can travel to using
portals this seems like it's Fran gila
riding into town here she's just another
nilfgaardian sorceress who's a big part
of the series then
see a very young version of yennefer
starting her training as a sorceress in
the brotherhood of sorcerers the woman
speaking to her here in the tower of
mages and all these different scenes
teaching her all these lessons is
Tissaia
she's the person that takes pity on
yennefer and takes her in and the reason
why she looks super messed up is that
she's born a hunchback in the books but
you don't get any of that because when
you see her in the books for the first
time she's already a sorceress and her
and Geralt relationship develops and
slowly he starts to learn about her
backstory through flashbacks so one of
the big things that the TV show is
adding is that it's giving you all that
yennefer backstory as you go along I
think it'll help explain a little bit
more about why she's kind of a dick the
first time she actually shows up in the
books like why is she so angry all the
time
oh it's because she had this terrible
terrible childhood her father used to
physically abuse her then eventually he
left their family her mother started to
blame her for their father leaving and
then she started to abuse yennefer as
well so she ran away and eventually
joined the brotherhood of sorcerers you
start to get all that dialogue about
people being really terrible and you see
what seems like the slaughter of syndra
so in the backdrop of this you have the
larger nilfgaardian wars that are going
on with nilfgaard trying to slowly
conquer all the neighbouring realms in
ciri is from Cintra so when you see her
walking around these castles here this
is all probably still in Cintra like
they say they're coming for you so
they're jumping forward in the story
just a little bit but there are a couple
really big conflicts like when you see
them charging the field here this could
be the Battle of sodden Hill or it could
be one of the final battles of the
nilfgaardian war the conquests and
massacre of Cintra there are just a
couple really huge battles that they
could have pulled from the books they
did cast pavetta I didn't see anybody
listed on the IMDB as Duny but that's
a bit of a secret if you haven't read
the books there are a couple big
spoilers that you learn about later on
in the book so we'll try to take that as
we get it because I think a lot of
people on previous videos like how come
you didn't give a spoiler warning for
this book backstory explainer so no
worries we can talk about Dooney pavetta
and how they tie in with ciri and her
storyline during the books and this big
prophecy there's a lot of bigger stuff
that it'll probably take a couple
seasons to get to but they didn't say
how many seasons of the show they're
gonna do so I'm hoping they go for five
seasons but not that many Netflix shows
go past three seasons I haven't seen all
the ones sheets
all the actors there's a whole bunch of
characters from the books but I believe
this person talking to Geralt is
supposed to be Mouse sack this scene of
yennefer and Geralt actually seems like
it's from the sorcerers banquet which is
much later in the books every once in a
while he's forced to go with her and do
something in a very official capacity so
when he's forced into situations where
he has to interact with all these high
society people it becomes kind of a
comedic situation where it just doesn't
want have anything to do with them like
he thinks that all these people are even
more terrible than a lot of the monsters
that he's hired to fight this character
here talking to you nifer is histor ed
he's just another mage at the tower of
mages that she develops a relationship
with when she's not with Geralt
eventually she's forced to choose
between the two of them but she does
have other relationships besides him
there are a couple really big characters
like vill gourds that do not appear in
the trailer that I know are in season 1
because they appear on the IMDB so
there's a couple really huge characters
that you might be wondering about that
they'll probably just save for the later
trailers but I like some of the special
effects I like Henry Cavill look if
you're wondering why he doesn't have a
beard it's because Geralt does not have
a beard in the books at least at the
beginning towards the end of the story
he starts to grow a beard so maybe
towards the end of this series in season
5 or whatever they decide to end it then
he'll grow a beard but if you have a lot
of questions about little things that it
seems like that they've changed most of
what they're going on from a visual
sense is based on what's described in
the books so that's why it might seem a
little bit different from what you've
seen if you played the games the trailer
makes it look really big but it'll be
kind of hard to tell exactly what's
going on until we just start getting
episodes so like I said supposed to
premiere some time towards the very end
of November very beginning of December
there'll be 8 episodes for season 1
there's a rumor that they've already
renewed it for season 2 because it's so
big and it cost so much money in Henry
Cavill schedule is so hard to plan
around do they just want to lock
everything down in advance but they
haven't made any official announcements
about future seasons beyond these first
eight episodes so just let me know what
you guys think of it in the comments if
you have any special requests for bonus
videos based on The Witcher mythology
but as we start to get more footage
later this year I'll do more videos so
no worries tomorrow is going to be the
big Marvel phase for Comic Con panel
I'll be doing videos for that and
there's a bunch of DC TV panels they'll
be dropping trailers for all the TV
shows and crisis on Infinite Earths
so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you'll see all the videos
when I post them but click here for that
brand new Rick and Morty season for
Comic Con trailer and click here for my
spider-man far from home a post-credits
scene Easter Egg video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome
happy Comic Con week!